sie werden es nicht glauben liebe
zuschauer aber deutschland diskutiert
zur abwechslung mal über flüchtlinge
wegen ellwangen und weil alexander
dobrindt anwälte attackiert die
asylbewerber vertreten ich habe wirklich
keine ahnung
ich habe keine ahnung was sie den doping
neuerdings ins futter rühren
aber der hat ja nur noch klopp heraus es
ist nicht akzeptabel dass eine anti
abschiebe industrie dafür sorgt dass die
bemühungen des rechtsstaates unterlaufen
werden
skrupellose anwälte marodieren durch
unsere straßen und nutzen dreist legale
rechtsmittel
ich sag mal so wenn ich in einer csu
wäre ich würde nicht gegen anwälte
hetzen
wie oft haben die euch raus gehauen wenn
ihr wieder besoffen leute überfahren
habt einfach noch mal drüber nachdenken
vielleicht lag es auch an der dünnen
luft da oben auf der zugspitze aber da
hat sich der alex sind eine ganz
bestimmte formulierung geradezu
verbissen haben wir festgestellt hier
alles aus einem interview und wir zählen
mit die abschiebung von kriminellen
asylbewerber wald bereite und kriminelle
asylbewerber kriminelle oder
gewaltbereite asylbewerber kriminellen
asylbewerber und gewaltbereite
asylbewerber gewaltbereite asylbewerber
kriminellen und gewaltbereiten
asylbewerber gewaltbereit oder kriegen
kriminelle und gewaltbereite erwäge
werden gewaltbereite und kriminelle
die bewerber stellen gewaltbereiten
asylbewerbern der stimmen erhielt
bewerber finden und gewaltbereit das
habe ich jetzt alles dreimal viermal
fünfmal gesagt gut danke
da bin ich dafür nicht gewaltbereit
hoffmann 13 mal müssen wir zwölf abzieht
was wir gerade gehört haben nennt man
fremming der zuschauer soll das wort
asylbewerber gar nicht mehr denken
können ohne den zusatz kriminell
dobrindt jetzt mal ernsthaft tritt bitte
endlich ein in die afg wirklich selbst
die afg hat es nicht verdient dass du
ihn ständig die ideenklaus hier kommen
wir haben für dich extra vorbereitet
dass afg starter kit ja da ist alles
drin was du brauchst komme hier die
original gauland hunde krawatte zum
beispiel
[Musik]
wie ist dies sogar noch hässlicher ist
seine karierten sakkos dann ihr guckt
man die beatrix von storch computermaus
aber vorsichtig darunter da rutscht man
ganz schnell von ab natürlich und jeder
mitgliedsantrag und ernsthaft wir von
der heute-show zahlen ja sogar die
beiträge für das erste jahr unerträglich
der dobrindt ich hoffe das war auch
thema beim groko treffen mit andrea
nahles
wenn sie unsere systeme die hand geben
[Gelächter]
schreckliche bilder
zur tatsache tatsache ist klar es hat
nichts gesagt sie will sie nicht mehr
schreiben
tatsache ist aber auch zur entlastung
unserer kommunen und damit die
integration der wirklich
schutzbedürftigen klappt müsste auch das
mit den abschiebungen besser klappen
aber das scheint sich aber immer genau
anguckt nicht an irgendwelchen anwältin
sondern zum beispiel am bundesamt für
migration und flüchtlinge kurz bam
dessen asylbescheide sind nämlich oft so
fehlerhaft sagen richter dass 44 prozent
der klagen dagegen
in erster instanz erfolgreich sind kein
wunder dass beim vier jahre lang
unterbesetzt und jetzt geht es nur noch
um tempo tempo tempo
wir sollten innerhalb weniger monate
hunderttausende von asylverfahren
abschließen
das war die oberste maxime wie diese
leistungen erbracht werden war
vollkommen zweitrangig und wenn keine
qualität gefordert wird dann arbeite ich
ebenso wie es gewünscht ist willkommen
das band monatelange mehr personal die
battle dann gab's crashkurse jetzt ist
das dabei herausgekommen aber demnächst
wird alles besser
mit horst seehofers anker zentren janker
anker klingt doch super
aber selbst da haben die guten menschen
von der anti abschiebe industrie schon
die da was zu meckern
ich würde mal sagen das ist dazu eine
art eine art einrichtung der
hoffnungslosigkeit seehofers anker
zentren so sollen sie funktionieren
anker steht für ankunft der entscheidung
rückführung deswegen heißt das anker
zentrum kurz im gespräch war auch der
name az hat sich aber nicht durchgesetzt
ich sage das ganz in gedanken ist im
grunde gedacht wieso eine drehtür ja wo
der asylbewerber vornherein geht und
wenn es optimal läuft direkt wieder raus
und jetzt kommt der hammer
in diesen zentren sagt seehofer sollen
behörden von bund land und kommunen
zusammenarbeiten
ich sag mal er gibt es frieden im nahen
osten bis zu 1500 asylbewerber sitzen
dann da monatelang ohne beschäftigung
ellwangen im quadrat
egal wir machen erstmal von den machern
von obergrenze transits ohne und
irgendwas mit kruzifixen kommt jetzt das
zentrum demnächst vielleicht hier ihr
bruder hier
hauptsache weit weg von unseren wählern
du verstehst nicht was genau so ein
anker zentrum macht mir auch nicht in
jedem fall irgendwas mit einer hohen
mauer drum kann gefängnis aber die türen
machen wir schon zu und zwar so lange
bis jeder in bayern die absolute
mehrheit
so lange bis über jeden asylantrag
entschieden ist anka zentrum ein spaß
für die ganze familie
wenn sie denn nachziehen dürfte darf sie
aber nicht
das wird super
fast sein
noch im sommer kommen bayern war
anka cent das ist alles teil von
seehofers masterplan für schnellere
abschiebung
im moment werden übrigens immer wieder
gut integrierte flüchtlinge mitarbeit
abgeschoben ganz einfach weil man weiß
wo die sind in der schule oder am
arbeitsplatz außerdem fordert die union
diese woche werteunterricht für
flüchtlinge damit die unsere werte
lernen so was ähnliches gibt es war
schon längst fast überall was klingt
halt so schön entschlossen
bild schneider unterrichtet ehrenamtlich
wert sekunde für geflüchtete jugendliche
ja müssen die kollegen hat das jetzt
auch überrascht dieser vorstoß bei noch
ist ja gar nicht geklärt welche werte da
überhaupt gemeint sind ja hallo herzlich
willkommen salam aleikum werte kunde
werte sind uns deutschen unglaublich
wichtig deshalb haben wir sogar die
wertstofftonne ganze welt beneidet uns
um unsere welt keinen respekt erklärt
wir können ist in praktischen wertstoff
übungen lernten und zuwanderer die
grundlagen unseres zusammenlebens die
katze kommt der kunde ist schon wichtig
aber natürlich muss man dann auch
deutsche unterrichten die unser
grundgesetz nicht richtig verstanden
haben die sauberkeit disziplin kehrwoche
alexander legst du bitte das handy weg
du ich bin das öl ein
so meine lieben korrekte deutsche
fußbekleidung im sommer barfuß in
sandalen fast sandalen mit socken ein
ganz wichtiger deutscher wert wer
fleißig ist der kann von seiner arbeit
leben gut es sei denn erst mini jobber
oder leiharbeiter oder erarbeitet bei
der post und ist mehr als zweimal krank
diese menschen nennen wir faule schweine
ehebruch ist in deutschland kein
verbrechen
dabei wird niemand hier gesteinigt wenn
ich also zum beispiel meinen mann
betrügen
wer hat den stein geworfen
und am allerwichtigsten unsere
christlich jüdischen wurzeln
man muss also an gott glaubt nein
ja das sind halt wurzeln
christlich-jüdische aber habt ähnlich
die juden vergesst die letztlich zählt
auch eigentlich nur dass hier
strafgesetzbuch und grundgesetz vor dem
gesetz sind alle menschen gleich
das heißt wenn du gegen ein gesetz
verstößt wirst du auch dafür bestraft
ende ja feisal was ist mit dem
vw-manager
jetzt müssen wir wirklich wirklich
langsamer als zu einem ende kommen
alexander leg das handy weg ich sage es
nur noch einmal gibt es hier
kannst du dir nach den ferien werte
kumpel weil werte wirklich wertvoll sind
[Applaus]